there's a lot of stuff I mean just the
way they talk English kids I mean if you
listen to two toddlers whining let's say
and when them's winding in an American
accent saying mom I want some water and
any of the English kid who sing mummy
could I have some more water they just
sound better
whining in English and I found you know
my kids were sort of sounding like
little Lord Fauntleroy from an early age
and they sound like just completely
alien children so one of them she must
have been like four or five and she says
mummy are these trousers suitable with
this top and I just thought who are you
you know where did that come from so all
that is weird the vocabulary is weird
you know every word for diapers they say
nappies and for stroller they say push
chair and you know their nursery rhymes
are different in there there it's just
you know they don't say achoo they say a
tissue when they're sneezing it's a
strange like a little skewed sense of of
what we have and they turned it around
90 degrees